Hi, everyone.
Welcome to another edition of
"YouTube Developers Live." My
name is Ikai Lan.
I'm a member of the YouTube
Developer Relations team.
And in today's show,
we are going to be
talking about GitHub.
Now, GitHub, if you haven't
heard of it before, it's a way
for people to share open-source
code and to
contribute to open source.
And as of very recently, we've
moved our code samples, as
well as some of our open-source
projects here at
YouTube, to GitHub.
So in today's show, we're going
to go over what GitHub
is, a rough overview of
what it looks like,
some basic Git commands.
This is not going to be a Git
tutorial, but I'm going to
give you enough so that you can
get started, as well as
some intro to some cool
Git tools like Git
GUIs that we use.
And at the end, we're going
to talk about how you can
contribute to our
Git projects.
And one final note, which is,
you know, how we like to end
the show, just a quick
commercial at
the end of the show.
So with that, why don't we
go ahead and get started?
Now, you may or may
not have noticed--
we haven't really made a lot
of noise around this, but
we've moved our API code
samples to GitHub.
They would previously be hosted
at code.google.com/
p/youtube-api-samples.
But now, it's much easier
to find them by going to
github.com/youtube.
So if you browse to
github.com/youtube, you'll see
that this is the home for all of
our API samples and some of
our open source projects.
So most of our samples follow
the naming convention of
yt-samples, and then the
name of the project.
So in this case, you'll see that
we have samples for Go,
JavaScript, Ruby, Python, and
most of the major programming
languages that we support.
So why don't we go ahead and
start looking at how we can
start working with GitHub.
Now, let's say that you
want to get at the
GitHub samples for Java--
the YouTube API samples.
You'd go to this page-- again,
that's github.com/youtube,
click on yt-samples-java, and
you'll see that this is a
project that we've been
contributing to.
So if you want to download this
sample code, what you
would do is you would go over to
the right-hand part of the
screen, and you'll
see Download ZIP.
And what's nice about this is
that you don't have to install
any clients.
You don't have to install Git.
You don't have to know
anything about Git.
You just hit Download, and you
should have code that can
work, that you can fork off
of and start working on.
So that's really cool.
But let's rewind a little bit
and talk about why Git?
Well, GitHub is where
developers are.
GitHub has a really good model
where you can create an Open
Source project, and people can
use what's called forking to
create a copy of your project
and contribute to that copy.
And people can recursively
keep doing this.
They can keep forking
the fork.
And what typically happens is
you have a canonical copy of a
project up in Git.
Like in this case, it's just in
the YouTube account under
yt-samples.java.
Someone might fork this, make
some changes, and they would
send what's called a
pull request to me.
A pull request is a way
of saying, hey,
I've made some changes.
I want you to check these out.
And I can go through and say,
do I want these changes or
not, and merge them in
or not merge them in.
And I think that's really cool
because if you think about the
old way in which you used to
contribute to open source, you
used to have to send a patch,
and it was really difficult.
And what's really nice about
this way is that I've seen
some projects where a fork has
actually overtaken the
canonical or main
original project
and become more popular.
And that's perfectly fine
because this is open source.
So more about Git, why
I like Git a lot.
Git is fast, right?
And if you come from a world
of SVN, or Subversion, you
know that Subversion is based
on the idea that you have a
central repository, and you're
copying from the repository,
whereas Git is more of a
decentralized system.
So GitHub is a centralized
system for a decentralized
SCM, Source Control
Management tool.
But you can run Git without
using GitHub.
And if GitHub goes down, you
could have a backup server
that you push to, and
you could do a lot
of really cool things.
So why don't we go ahead
and do a quick
introduction to Git?
If you don't have Git installed,
you can go ahead
and search for Git.
That's spelled G-I-T. And if
you're using something like
Ubuntu, and you want to install
the packages git-core.
So sudo apt-get git-core will
get you the tools you need.
You can also download some
packages that will make your
life easier.
I've downloaded this for Mac.
Now I've already done, this so
I'm not going to go through
this process.
But here I am in a terminal.
I'm in a temp directory,
so I can
basically trash this directory.
Now, I have Git already.
And if I hit Git, I'm going to
get a bunch of commands.
So the first thing we're going
to want to do if we want to
track the project, if we don't
just want to download the zip
file, is we want to go to
the GitHub page, right?
And we want to find
the clone URL.
So right here, this is the
clone URL, right here.
And I guess you can clone with
Subversion, but typically
that's not something
I commonly see.
So I'm going to go ahead and
copy this to my clipboard.
Now I'm going to go back
into Terminal.
I'm going to type, "Git clone."
I'm going to paste the
repository in here,
and there you go.
I've cloned the whole thing.
Now, that was pretty quick.
I have a fast network connection
here, but I
guarantee you Git
is really fast.
It's really, really
cool stuff.
So if I go in here, I'll see
that I have all the projects
for the Java sample code, and I
can start running this on my
local machine.
We're using Maven nowadays, so
is you have Maven, you can
start building this, running
this, importing it into your
IDE, all that cool stuff.
Now, Git is very, very fast,
like I mentioned.
And one of my favorite commands
is to use a Git Log.
And a Git Log--
I'm going to pipe this into more
so I can paginate it--
a Git Log tells me
all the commits
that have been happening.
And it doesn't show me the code,
but there is a verbose
mode so I can see all the
different diffs of what I've
been doing in Git.
But hopefully, you won't need
to be doing this too much if
you're just getting started.
And let's say we make an update
to the repository.
Let's say we push some
new code to fix bugs
or add a new feature.
What would you do?
Well, you would usually
type, "git pull."
And this is going to check to
see if you have the latest
version of code.
And I do have the latest
version of code, and it
doesn't do anything.
So this is really cool, and
you can start working with
things right away.
When you start to want to make
changes, you want to learn
about git add as well
as git commit.
And like I said, this
is not going to be a
tutorial about Git.
One of the best books
on Git is actually
free in open source.
It's over here.
Just search for "Git Book." And
you can find this on the
main Git home page.
This is written by one of the
founders of GitHub, and it's a
very, very good,
detailed book.
But I can understand that
sometimes you just might want
to get started much quicker.
So there are a couple of good
Git quick starts on the web.
But over time, if you're getting
into Git, I would
highly recommend reading this
book only because there's a
lot of more advanced usages.
You want to learn about
how branching works.
Branches are very, very cool.
Whereas in something like
Subversion, you want to avoid
branching, and in Git you always
want to be branching.
You always want to be merging.
With Git, since a lot of things
are local, when I do a
check in, I don't need to be
online to do a Git check in.
So you could be on a plane, you
could be on a train, and
you could be writing code and
just making small changes.
So that's all really
cool stuff.
Now, I'm going to show you one
more thing, which I think is
really cool.
I tend to like use command
line, and I would highly
recommend you use the
command line.
But Git has become so popular
that Git has now integrated
with lots of the popular IDEs.
For instance, if I'm writing a
project in IntelliJ, that has
Git integration, it'll
tell me which lines
have I changed, right?
Like, which lines have I added
since the last commit.
And in Git, it is a best
practice to always be
committing, because commits are
so fast and local that you
should be committing lots and
lots of small atomic changes
before essentially merging back
into master head, which
you could think of this as
merging back into trunk.
This is something you
do very common.
So Git doesn't map to other
source controls, like
Subversion, one to one because
the workflow is a little bit
different, but it's something
you get used to.
So I tend to like the Command
Line for doing pulls, doing
pushes, as well as
doing commits.
I don't like using GUI tools
for those things.
But I do like using GUI tools.
And when you go to Git home
page, you'll see some of the
many GUI tools.
Many of these are free.
Some of these are paid.
And the one that is becoming
really popular is called
GitHub for Mac.
Now, I've got this installed
for you guys, and where I
really like to use GUI
tools is for Git Log.
I can very quickly see what's
different, I can scroll up and
down, and I can do this
much more easily than
I can in the terminal.
So you'll see that green is
stuff that we've added, and
we've just done an import, so
most of the stuff is green.
But let's see, here
are some changes.
Oh, what have we done?
Oh, there was a problem
with the XML file.
We removed a line and
we added a line.
I'm not sure what
we did there.
I think we just deleted a space
or converted tabs to
spaces, or something
weird like that.
And what's also nice
is branches.
And we haven't been doing much
branching here, but the GUI
will very quickly visualize
where you have branched, where
you have merged, and [INAUDIBLE]
to diffs quickly.
So again, if you've never
looked at Git, I highly
encourage you to do it.
It's a very, very cool system.
So that's a Git GUI.
That's a Git book.
So I just wanted to go ahead
and introduce all of these
things to you.
And again, you don't need
to know how to do this.
You can just go to
github.com/youtube, click on
Project, and click
on Download ZIP.
When we go back GitHub Project,
you'll see that
mostly what's in here
is sample code.
But we host the code for YouTube
Direct, YouTube Direct
Lite in here, as
well as some of
YouTube's open-source projects.
So this is where we will be
committing our resources in
the future, and I encourage
you to look here.
We will be starting to put
pointers on code.google.com to
start pointing to
our GitHub page.
So that's what I have
for you guys today.
Hopefully I didn't take
too much of your time.
And there's one last thing that
I wanted to talk about,
which is I have an announcement
to make.
And that announcement is that
our team is hiring.
So if you're interested in
joining Developer Relations,
come to
developers.google.com/jobs.
Let me just verify that
that's a working URL.
It would be really embarrassing
if it weren't.
Yes, it is.
So go to our page,
developers.google.com/jobs.
Again, my name is Ikai Lan.
Thank you guys for joining in
for the show, and hope to see
you guys on GitHub soon.
Take care.